hey everybody and welcome to a timeless
wild ride with stevo this one's a lot of
fun we've got andy milinakis who is a
wildly talented
super hilarious entertainer who's had a
career spanning decades and he's going
to share with us
the most epic song try not to laugh out
loud when you hear it it's just a
refreshing time with this podcast and
speaking of refreshing i'm gonna take a
stab at this and guess that you need to
get a new mattress because your old
one's disgusting
and i'm telling you if you go to helix
sleep.com
stevo you're going to get up to 200 off
of any mattress you choose but don't
just choose any mattress because if you
take their just two-minute sleep quiz
then they will pick out the
perfect mattress for you not even pick
it out it's science man plus you can
take the quiz with your partner and
they're gonna match the two of you to
the perfect mattress for you both and
there are a lot of things you're going
to fight with your partner about but
your mattress does not have to be one of
them don't go to bed angry go to bed
happy in a helix mattress
now once more it's helix sleep.com
stevo where you go and take this quick
two-minute quiz you get matched up with
the perfect mattress for you and you get
up to 200 off plus two free pillows
telling you it's a great deal it's a
great mattress and it's good people
making them so go get that mattress and
let's get into it
all right rolling
rolling
all right
we're rolling everywhere
once i get that
would do it like this oh yeah man
ladies and gentlemen andy milinakis
hello fine sir yeah dude so you've met
scott randolph yeah what's up bro the
gorgeous paul briskey
hello sexy [ __ ] oh it's been a
while since i saw you last time was uh
you had some kind of a cooking show if i
were you yeah
um
[ __ ] i don't know how long that was it
might have been like eight years ago or
something
we're getting old it's it's it's
exciting it's crazy we get older you
just stay the same
um
it's also it's crazy because like
i feel like you know people say like
time flies but like let's get you going
into that mic yeah uh i i feel like
people say like time flies like some
[ __ ] feels like really slow but when
it's like just how your brain processes
memories and when you kind of like
think about like that day or some day
that happened 10 years ago
in your mind it just feels like it was
like a short amount of time and it feels
like damn that was eight years ago
somebody said the future is long and the
past is short yeah i don't know about
that was that kanye west yeah
lil wayne i remember like when i was a
little kid i noticed
that
like each new school year
passed more quickly
than the year before it and the time
generally sped up
as you go you know you fly through time
more the older you like senior year
flies junior years like kindergarten is
just like giving you a reality here you
know
when you're five a year is a fifth of
your life
exactly what joe rogan said i thought
that was so [ __ ] g you can't talk
about him right now he's cancelled
yo i remember i brought that up with joe
rogan he's like yeah it's like the it's
a smile that's exactly what you just
said huh um
you know i have a weird thing with
nostalgia and
i went to like work where i grew up not
too long ago in new york
and what's crazy to me about nostalgia
when i think about like my early early
childhood
i
don't just have memories of it but i
have memories in a weird way it's like
before you knew that death existed
before you knew
you know that
death was something that everybody has
to face and you know you're we're all
going to die
there's something different about your
mind and your joy and just like the way
you went through life when you kind of
had like pretty much no problems and
[ __ ]
um and like my nostalgia like i think
about like why it feels so good because
i'm like i think like
paired with my old memories is like the
the also the thrill and the feeling that
like this [ __ ] was gonna go on forever
okay
i think uh
fear of death is an interesting
uh
point to i think the kids are generally
more joyful
and i don't know that it's because
they're aware or not aware of of their
mortality i think that
that uh
i don't know and then there's also that
like when you're born you're like at
your most like
wise and knowledgeable
and then you forget more
yeah i guess so i kind of have a crazy
memory like i i smoke a lot of weeds
sometimes my short-term memory like it's
kind of like whack but like
i mean i have like vivid memories from
preschool
good man i don't know yeah and you're
saying it's not just the memory of what
happened but you're also remembering
like that the feeling
yeah i remember exactly where i was when
i was like four years old when i when i
thought about infinity i was like i'm
gonna be here forever yeah
and then i remember i went and cried to
my mom and i asked her what happens when
you die
i remember i remember the first time i
came to the realization that i was gonna
die that everyone's gonna die i remember
like
my one of my aunts
what like the
we're reading a book and like something
happened in the book and she's like oh
yeah we're all gonna die and i was like
no
yeah yeah i mean this is off to a deep
start yeah i love this start yeah so um
is it safe to say that you are
like
the godfather of the
[ __ ]
youtube diss track
youtube disneyland
very very early in there with like a
pioneer i mean like when when youtubers
got into doing diss tracks specifically
i think of rice gum did you
i did and i i feel like i usually don't
say things so egotistical i feel like
i'm the godfather of youtube i mean all
right i was making i was making viral
videos before youtube existed i had to
put it on a website
with like three different files like one
was mov for mac one was a wmv for pc and
then a zip file for people who didn't
have internet fast enough so they had to
download the video like
don't get me wrong you guys are like
godfathers of content too a hundred
percent like right i had like cky
[ __ ] like videos like all the old
jackass [ __ ] but like
i didn't beat youtube by that much but i
beat it by years and i had like hundreds
of videos online on a website that
people could click on when people
weren't really making online content
like that it was like for youtube
because you and tom green you and tom
green i was gonna say the same thing uh
paul brought up uh
a prolific
viral video that you made before youtube
which was called the super bowl is gay
true true back when it was okay to call
stuff gay yeah and it's kind of crazy
that like that wouldn't fly now at all
and like
i got a whole career
yeah that's great and it was just like
it wasn't about the word gay it was just
about
like nonsensical randomness you know
what i mean sure i mean my my girl her
name is lux
and uh you know she's dabbled in in some
uh
you know like uh carpet super bowl
she she dabbled in a uh
some [ __ ] eating you know
and uh
shamesies and and uh she's really really
like
you know
not okay with
anything offensive she's very very
particular about about like and she's
with stevo
said something i was like dude that's
gay
yeah like not meaning anything hateful
towards homosexual people yeah but just
as a synonym for uh
like that's lame or that you know yeah
the people like us who just kind of like
if you look at movies in like the 80s
and 90s and just how we grew up and like
i'm not saying it was right back then
but it just kind of like was part of our
vocab
and not everybody used it in a
homophobic way it wasn't it's not a
hateful homophobic thing and
but we were not using it like that
exactly yeah and to be clear like lux
and i arrived at the point that it's
like hey let's just find a better
adjective than that
yeah but back then that was the one to
use yeah and like there was like kids
movies where they were calling each
other hard f-bombs like it was just like
that was just kind of like a
snarky little jokey thing for a 15 year
old to call his friend
and it was just part of pop culture too
right and i understand why it's kind of
different now i get it i'm not gonna
like fight against that you know right
it's like a weird thing to try to fight
against because i could see how it
how it really you know [ __ ] people over
and it makes people feel like [ __ ] you
know um
the uh
tell us some of the people that you've
made diss tracks against
um
well it's funny i made a diss track
about justin bieber
whoa if andy melinakis makes a diss
track on you better watch out because
there's a good chance he's gonna murder
you with it just like liquid death
murders your thirst if you haven't heard
about this company it's time to get on
board because they're epic all right
it's water which comes in a tall boy can
which is designed to look like a beer
because they think it's hysterical for
little kids to drink it in school and
have the teachers think that they're
drinking beer
man just a good attitude this company
has and they're out to save the world
people because these cans are made in
infinitely recyclable aluminum that's
right man they're swearing death to
plastic and that means they're trying to
save the world over here plus they're
going to save you a whole lot of money
if you go to liquiddeth.como
then as much water and merch as you feel
like ordering your shipping is for free
and here's a news flash water weighs a
lot man i can't believe they're shipping
for free dude jump on this fill your
fridge with liquid death and i'll tell
you that the sparkling water that i'm
holding right here man that's the best
way to get off that disgusting fattening
unhealthy soda that you're drinking
switch to liquid death man for a much
healthier you and a much healthier world
one more time for free shipping on all
your orders of water and merch go to
liquiddeth.com
stevo save the world now let's hear
about that diss track
just for the hell of it while he was
popping and i was just you know making
silly rap songs
and then
can you help us with uh some of the
stuff you said in your justin bieber
dude it was so long ago i don't remember
but there's a funny finish to this
because his friend ryan was a big fan of
my show
and at the time i think we had each
other on like aim or one no not aim it
was something with video maybe it was
like i chat or something right
so one day i get like a video request
call and i'm thinking it's ryan i
haven't really talked to him on video at
all i just talked to him on the internet
[ __ ] i met him once
and i answered the call and it was just
[ __ ] justin by himself
i'm like what the [ __ ] i'm like where
was he a little kid at that point ah
no it was like when never say never came
out so i don't know maybe he was like
almost 18 or around that age i don't
really remember
um
and he's like what's up and he he like
said he saw one of my song my videos
would look like uh little b
and i was like i don't know why the
first thing i said to him was like yo
did you see my diss track on you and he
goes he goes no no i don't care about
that though but uh
he was uh
he hit me up because he wanted me to
make a little video promoting his movie
oh i guess he liked me or whatever he
yeah so i was just like for [ __ ]
justin bieber okay so i made a little
video in my elevator of my apartment
building i sent it to him and he goes
okay i like it and then he posted it to
his facebook to i don't know how many
millions of people
um and then i never got to meet him but
then like 10 years later i just get
blown the [ __ ] up on instagram and he
took like one of my old show clips and
posted it on his insta so i mean he's
he's got love for me even though i
apparently made a diss track on him
couldn't have been too uh
you know no it wasn't too mean it was
light-hearted so yeah i did the thing
with rice gum
that was kind of like fake we kind of
told him like it was in the era of
youtube distraction we kind of told him
we were gonna make a diss track on them
was that when they're doing rap battles
at maker
um probably around that time i was
trying to make her for a while okay um
but yeah so me and jesse wellins did
this rap track
against him and uh then you know he did
one back and uh i don't know who else i
did one on i think i made one i did one
like youtube comments like tell me who
you want me to diss next type [ __ ] and
like someone said fred i don't know if
you remember fred he had like a sped-up
voice it was really annoying like
i was like and i was like this guy sucks
um i'm sure the person behind the
character doesn't suck but that
character sucked so i did one on him so
there weren't that many i guess maybe i
made like i remember the uh rice gum
diss track as such like a prolific thing
and i think that
that that you did it well you're a
talented rapper thanks man even tom
green man
yeah me and tom green we recorded
something together i don't think we ever
released it though but
but tom's the homie like i've hung out
with him a bunch over the years when he
was doing his like live show
yeah i was on that a few times that was
before youtube right it started before
youtuber i think so yeah yeah i am
yeah i really like his company he's uh
he's he's
he's like polarizing like
obviously he's not always like crazy and
in character but you just don't know
what he's gonna say he has like
his takes on stuff are a little bit
shifted but in a good way right yeah he
uh i got i loved the tom green show man
i was such a fan me too definitely a big
inspiration and i caught him at the
right time so like there's a there's a
guy who like follows both of us
he's been kind of on our twitter feeds
for a while and he just hit me up and
he's like i was in tokyo i go to japan a
lot and he's like yo tom's in town he's
doing stand-up so i hit tom up and he
goes bro i only have like a half a day
free but i definitely want to meet up
it's crazy that we're in tokyo together
so i was doing live streaming i've been
doing like travel like
i don't know if you know what irl
streaming is it's twitch right it's like
twitch but instead of playing games you
have a backpack with a camera and you
stream like travel stuff okay it's a
really niche thing not a lot of people
do it 99.9 of the people are just
playing games or at home
just talking to the camera right but
so
what is the duration of an average irl
twitch stream honestly if you want to
make money and you want to be big on
twitch like you know we do like six
hours minimum
like yeah yeah sometimes i i'd be out in
tokyo
killing all my batteries doing like 10
to 12 hour days like so so are you
reading the comments as it's coming in
and like really engaged the whole time
yeah 100 so the setup is really cool
there's a backpack there's four mobile
routers then i have a selfie stick with
like a wide-angle sony camera and then
under it i have a clamp with a big phone
on it and the phone is segmented into
two pieces
the right half is all chat room and the
left half is all alerts when people
subscribe to you and they donate to you
wow so uh
so i was like yo tom i was like i'm
doing the stream like people would love
to see you if you want to just meet up
for lunch just me and you that's totally
cool but if you want to be on the stream
let me know and i'll bring it and we'll
have some fun and he goes yeah bring it
bring it of course he did and uh
he killed it there's so many like viral
clips from that from him we were walking
around
and i just was like you know we went to
get sushi we did have we did we did a
karaoke stream and he was singing like
material girl he's like i am ah material
girl
[ __ ] really funny [ __ ]
there's a bit about like there was like
this
trendy ass table with a zipper in the
middle and he just goes to this couple
he goes
that's like a zipper like you zip your
pants
it's like you zip your pants
it's like you zip the zipper like on you
on your pants and he just carried on
where the way he does yeah um well yeah
that was really [ __ ] legendary i'm so
happy i get to hang out in tokyo why do
you always go to japan
i mean come on why does anybody go
anywhere
to get their dick wet baby
and i'm telling you if you want to get
your dick wet then best to get it real
hard first and you know how you do that
with blue chew tablets baby
they are a lot of fun man what are they
well they are delicious chewable tablets
which have the same active ingredient as
both viagra and cialis except they only
cost a fraction of the price and man i
can get you an entire month's supply of
them absolutely for free all you gotta
pay is five bucks for shipping now i
think you might be wondering but don't
you need a prescription for those well
yeah you do but with bluetooth tablets
you don't have to have an awkward
in-person visit to the doctor because
when you go to bluechew.com
you consult with the medical provider
right there on the site it's not awkward
at all it's very simple it's very fast
and when you're done you plug in the
promo code stevo and boom the tablets
are on the way an entire month's supply
of epic boner tablets that you don't
have to pay a penny for you just pay
five bucks for shipping now if you've
ever wondered are these a lot of fun i'm
gonna tell you as a fact yes they are a
lot of fun i love chewing my bluetooth
tablets and then taking lux to bone town
so jump on this deal bluetooth.com with
the promo code stevo and you and your
wiener are gonna have a blast
yeah dude now let's talk about japan
first of all i just love japan it's so
[ __ ] fun i feel like if you could go
one place
where you take off in a plane and land
somewhere where it feels like you're on
a different planet i feel like it's it's
tokyo you know i love tokyo yeah and it
just
it's like
to me it's like new york city inside of
a lucid dream but clean and organized
think about how boring a lot of cities
are it's like restaurant bar restaurant
bar store restaurant bar tokyo is so
[ __ ] weird bro i love it it's just so
strange you're like oh a maid cafe some
octopus thing themed cupcake store like
it's it's just so weird it feels like a
weird dream and i just have so much fun
walking around it's really safe like i
love tokyo you do like super long trips
there you go yeah i go there for like a
month minimum wow wow yeah but also
because i'm there to live stream because
it's like a fun place to stream so i'm
like
it's like definitely fun but it's like a
work fun thing too if i was going there
just to relax and chill
i'd maybe do like two weeks but since
i'm like kind of working and making
money while i'm there i'll stay for a
long time you know yeah do you have uh
like relationships that you've developed
with people who are like die hard glued
to your twitch stream
yes
um a lot of them i don't but some of
them like the way they handle it if they
just show up while i'm like out and
they're just like kind of like
they're weird about it then maybe not
but if i like their personality and i
think they're cool like i'm not gonna
let just them
me meeting them because they were like a
fan or whatever get in the way of that
you know some people are cool about it
they're like hey i know you're i know
where you are i'm in tokyo is it cool if
i stop by for a drink and i'm like yeah
[ __ ] it they'll come by get a drink and
then like you know if i like the person
that's that's enough for me you know i
mean cool man yeah so so i
i'm guessing that that's like the major
source of revenue that's like the number
one revenue stream for you it has been
for like probably like five years
because i've been putting so much hour
so many hours into it
uh but lately i've been kind of like
diving more into crypto and nft [ __ ]
i've been making more music so like i've
been out in l.a for like two months i've
been working on i'm writing this like
kind of like crypto cartoon with some
friends
um and i haven't streamed in like a
month and a half because oh [ __ ] i see
you on tik tok quite a bit yeah i just
you know i really was against tick tock
when it started because it was just like
kids lip syncing and then i was like wow
it's like a different app now people
there's like professional chefs
all these crafts and i was like it was
like in greece
in august and i was like you know what
i should just give it a go now it feels
like a different platform now and i just
went for it
and i just i've been pretty active on it
for the last six months yeah i get all
my kryptonius from tick tock that's
funny
probably the worst place to do it yeah
no i'm just kidding i've made bets off
of like something that like you know
some bad decisions some [ __ ] things i
lost i lost sleep overnight because i'm
on this altcoin right now that i like i
can wake up and you know it's either
going to 5x or you know maybe just
completely tank and have too much money
and some do you want to talk about which
coin or no um i mean is that bad yeah
okay i'm just curious i'm always
interested it's called cheddar
yeah
c-h-e-d-d-a that's probably pretty cool
um
but yeah i mean so far i put like 25k
and i'm like up to like i think like 150
or something wow that's crazy like that
i you know i honestly believe that if i
invest in something
that's
the tanks because that your investment
did so well because i had nothing to do
well thank you
you'd be good with some of the stuff
that's less risky you know there's like
a volatility scale like there's some
[ __ ] that's like pretty safe you don't
want to put a lot in the cheddar but
like uh right yeah unless you're [ __ ]
degenerate like me yeah but don't you
want to take like your your initial i
did i took little pieces out yeah i'm
i'm like sniping little pieces and
taking some out yeah
i think i probably took my whole initial
investment back right that's great
something like that
yes man so uh you said the crypto and
the nfts and you're back to making music
yeah yeah i just made and i just made a
couple new songs last week
and and
that brings in revenue the music so
you're getting it from spotify
well
now that
nfts are kind of fully developed like
you can actually do music nfts
so i already have an nft series that's
like fully on chain they're like pic
it's like pixel art and i'm not gonna
really make money off my first couple
songs because i want to make it a free
mint for people who already bought my
series like i want to keep adding on
your series a series of nfcs yeah so
they bought my series at nfts and i want
to kind of like sort of a thank you gift
yeah like i'm going to start throwing
some like parties for people who hold
you know hold go goat soup is the name
of these series um
you know
have free music nfts that they can
resell if they want um
i'm working on trying to get them three
put into the 3d sandbox world which is
like a metaverse
um and
i'd like it i don't know what the deal
is going to be like yet i have a call
with them tonight but i'd like for it to
be
anybody who already owns my series can
get
a free 3d version of it that they can
walk around and play in the metaverse i
just want to keep adding stuff that they
already get for free for supporting and
being a part of the nft because a lot of
nft [ __ ] is scammy and a lot of [ __ ] you
have an image and it just sits there and
the price goes up and down and then the
[ __ ] devs or the creator does nothing
and it's kind of like called like a rug
pull where you're just like you take the
money and you kind of run and you don't
do any work
but i don't want to be a scumbag
obviously i did it for a reason and i
want to keep growing it
keep adding utility and keep adding
value to the people that are holding
this stuff cool
now i understand that you're
just over the top talented straight from
the dome freestyler
that's a big setup
i do freestyle like i feel like
yeah talk to me about like actually just
coming up with like if i were to
give you um
a uh
just a topic a couple topics you would
be able to weave them into a free stuff
yeah the thing with freestyling is it's
not like riding a bike like
you
i could probably do okay and then
sometimes i trip up and i do bad and you
slip up and it's just kind of like when
you're when i'm done with it i've been
freestyling for a long time when i'm
done with the freestyle like it's always
assorted my my feeling about it is
always assorted sometimes i'm like that
was so whack i [ __ ]
did horribly let me do one to make up
for it or like oh that was pretty good
or like
like i feel like when i'm stoned i i'm
the best because
the way my brain multitasks words i feel
like it's the best when i'm like a
little bit baked are you a little baked
now no ah damn it but i feel like i you
know like if you put out
i'll do it i'm not i'm never scared to
freestyle if you gave me a topic or two
i could try to put some words together
paul's a an unbelievable musician well
cool he's not just come out with his
first album nice it's uh it's called
that kid is you it's it's like
really [ __ ] impressive um thanks dude
what about uh
okay how about that the topic is
like
you know
i i'm just saying that paul briskey is
very attractive
okay he's having a popper's keys have
been missing um paul briskey yeah paul
briskey that's right paul briskey i want
to get frisky i'll suck your dick i
don't need no whiskey cause you're kinda
cute i wanna put two in your poop shoot
that's my two fingers i got zingers oh
my god i got bees on my head no stingers
yeah are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah i
said no mixed feelings about that that
was solid as [ __ ]
i'm feeling good about that with eye
contact too which i appreciate
dude i'm blushing over here
i mean dude thank you for that brother
that was uh
that that was that was a big honor i
just i was like man i'm gonna put him on
the spot what's the most what's the most
nervous you've ever been to freestyle
like oh like i'm in front of method band
or something like that so i actually ran
to bethany while i was streaming and i
did see that we're in new york no in uh
in l.a like on fairfax or something
right yeah he was like singing my theme
song and i'm like this is a [ __ ]
honor bro this guy like i'm the biggest
wu tank fan like my top three favorite
rap groups of all time i think
wu tang trav call quest and probably
like nwa
like and you know there's so many good
groups like bowling thugs and [ __ ] but i
feel like wu tang is definitely
probably like my number one um but my my
most nervous
time freestyling you want to talk about
nervous well the story andy's about to
tell might make you feel overwhelmed
with anxiety and stress
it's so intense
and
i'll admit i was feeling overwhelmed
with anxiety and stress and you know
what i did i got into therapy and i'm
proud to say that because getting into
therapy doesn't mean there's anything
wrong with you just means that you're
taking care of your mental health man
just like you keep your car tuned up so
it doesn't break down hey man that's how
i see it and you know how i got into
therapy i went to
betterhelp.com yeah man it was very
simple they asked me what my issues were
what i wanted to work on i plugged it in
and they matched me with the perfect
therapist yeah like they've got a whole
network of super qualified professional
therapists and if you go to
betterhelp.com that's b e t t e r h e l
p dot com slash stevo then you get 10
off your first month and i believe in it
man i do it it very much helped me and i
think there's a good chance that it
could help you too so go to betterhelp
betterhelp.como
give it a shot
and you get 10 off your first month and
i think there's a strong chance that you
might be a happier healthier person for
doing it so thank you to better help for
sponsoring this podcast and hooking up
the listeners of the wild ride yeah baby
now let's talk about that stressful
situation
so like i came up because jimmy kimmel
found me on the internet he found super
super bowl game yeah
so i was
doing his show for a while
and he just was learning about me he
just saw my little weird videos but he
didn't really see
any rap videos i don't think and so i
was in the alley like outside of his
show
freestyling for some random people i was
probably drunk or something and he came
out to like leave and he heard it and he
goes that's really good and then the
[ __ ] next day or two days later i'm
on as a guest announcer and [ __ ]
shaquille o'neal is like
the guest
and live on [ __ ] tv he's like
oh i heard shaquille you you had a rap
album you know our announcer over there
andy he's a he's a freestyle rapper too
andy why don't you give them some
freestyle lines
like i got a freestyle to shaquille
o'neal and it's on tv so if i wow
how much of a chance do you have you
spit four bars and if they suck they're
just gonna go to the next segment you
know what i mean i don't really have
time to like try to do good or try to
save it well i didn't give you any time
yeah too true
i
did okay i did okay i wasn't like i
murdered that [ __ ] dog but like i did
okay i was like thank god i i had words
i didn't slip up i rhymed without being
like uh uh uh so i was like i was like
okay i'll give myself a pass on that
dead epic man getting anybody realizing
that it's genuinely coming out of thin
air is gonna
have it have like a lower bar so are you
surprised how many rappers don't
actually freestyle off the top of the
head they just call everything a
freestyle on the radio yo yo we got
so-and-so
here and he's here to freestyle and it's
just all written verses yeah of course
and then someone will actually freestyle
so it's not as good as the written one
and people like oh that was kind of
whack but like he's the only dude that
actually really did it i could i i
there's like 99.9 of the time i could
tell if it's a freestyle or not when you
have like metaphors and like crazy
references and it flows together
perfectly
99.9 of the time that [ __ ] is not off
the head who's the best freestyler
um little dickie
well that his was written on his wrist
his little dick is a dope rapper but he
doesn't
like there's a guy named idea who passed
away a long time ago who used to battle
eminem and he was like [ __ ] one of
the best of all time
idea what about that guy that walks
around venice and he gets three words
shout out to harry mack true true i will
never not respect harry mack's freestyle
ability he's one of the best living i
think it's the best rap you've ever
heard in your entire life and it's
that's freestyle right yeah i mean i
don't know i don't know if it's the best
rap i've heard in my life but freestyle
wise like [ __ ] like 10 out of 10.
he's up there off the top of the head 10
out of 10.
that's cool
are you still buddies with jim jimmy
kimmel have you kept in touch
lately because i moved back to new york
for a couple years ago i haven't really
talked to him in a while and also like
there's so many people that come in and
out of his life that that do
entertainment and you know i had a kind
of
i was not just a one-off you know he
[ __ ] produced my whole show and i was
like where the [ __ ] was the mtv show
yeah he's the one who got me my mtv show
wow i didn't know that he did that
that's sick yeah
so
tony desanto was an mtv exec and was
always going to jimmy saying let's do a
show let's do a show let's do a show
jimmy was like really really busy
and then like a year so after he found
me he kept telling me he's like all the
bits on on my show are good but i think
your original comedy that i found you
from those weird little videos you did
on the internet i think that could be
something so
he finally like found the time he
brought me in
and he pitched me to them he's like
finally i got a show for you
we did a pilot
[ __ ] was jimmy kimmel ever on the
show he was yeah he was one of the
guests
um and he's very [ __ ] loyal man he's
like super like even
in the last like
not in the last few years but like maybe
five six years ago i had some other
ideas he like helped me pitch
he's like
took time out of his day to like be in a
video pitch to help me pitch other [ __ ]
like he's a very loyal [ __ ] cool dude
like yeah i know him a lot yeah very
gentle yeah i like him a lot too man i i
really do you ever go to one of his
crazy parties that you hear about yeah
the best one for a fat [ __ ] like me is
like um there's an italian
thing i think it's on new year's or
around new year's
where they don't eat meat they only eat
seafood and they make like seven or
eleven different i think it's a seven
fish
seven fishes yeah so just like i'm a big
seafood fan and he just had like seven
different kinds of like seafood at this
big ass [ __ ] party
that [ __ ] was fire what kind of parties
did you throw dude like you heard about
it on like howard stern and [ __ ] it's
just like
straight and nothing but [ __ ]
like a-list
you know george clooney's [ __ ] at the
party and like just like i don't think
i've been to that because that's
probably
like
i was on a show and my show came out and
the
kind of the earlier years of his show
so like i did more kind of like intimate
things where it was just like six people
going to
watch football and he's such a
workaholic he would be in his room for
half the time like writing and [ __ ]
right um and like yeah like the
new year's party type [ __ ] but not like
the whole actor [ __ ] you know what i
mean yeah like knoxville would be at
those parties and stuff and like this
because it's just crazy man like it's
the stuff of legends
wow yeah
it's epic
um do you have any uh any beefs going on
now or any anybody that we want to uh
attack honestly i never
i i never really have any beefs like i
don't think you do i talk sh i talk [ __ ]
to people online people like don't feed
the trolls i'm like i like roasting
people it's so fun
people are so [ __ ] dumb and i'm like
it's like fun to point that out
sometimes yeah i mean right let's hear
uh
some of this music you told me about
okay cool
yeah so you're saying you just made this
new song i made this like three days ago
not even out yet no it's not out
how long did it take you to make um
if it doesn't come quick then a couple
hours yeah
and are you sorry do you produce the
music as well no you don't produce i
always wanted to learn producing but i'm
like i can work with producers that have
10 years experience i'm like i'm never
going to be as good as the people i
could work with so i'm like that's not a
good excuse if you really want to learn
it learn it but sure i never really did
but yeah this song is called free snacks
[Music]
now you're making the instrumentals here
every day
is
[Music]
now when do you know you have a hit
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
dude yeah you see this had arenas dude
yeah it seems like you could have a
really hard rapper come come in with a
verse on that yeah true killer i am like
some gangsters
um
yeah you know
there's a lot of like
kind of comedy rap i feel like not
everybody's utilizing kind of like
sing-songy melodic auto-tune with like
right funny lyrics i mean i wanted to go
to bed to that
yeah i mean
um so tell us about this new movie that
that uh
all right the new movie uh
wait where were you at the time you said
you were in some oh yes so my father my
father's from greece i go there a lot i
have a lot of relatives there
and
then i get
an uh a text or email from matthew greg
gubler who's
the lead actor in the movie
who i've become friends with over the
years and
he's like man i got this independent
movie i really wanted to be in it i
think it'd be cool
and i read it and i was like i like this
i want to be in this
and they're like oh we're shooting in
like
i don't know they said like in a week or
10 days whatever it was
whatever it was i had to like cut my
trip short
i had to change my tickets and i had to
[ __ ] leave
um i think like maybe a week or 10 days
early or something which i was like not
happy about i'm like yeah i mean [ __ ]
that guy dude
i'm like in greece i'm just laughing
going to island hopping and [ __ ] were
you going to lindsay lohan's uh mike
canos no so mykonos and santorini are
like the disney world of greece they're
like fake greece
all right we're just like where do you
go
my father's from the island of crete
which is the biggest island there's tons
of culture there amazing beaches and
stuff like that but that that's like
biased right because that's like where
my heritage is that's really fun troy
right
i don't know if they film troy there but
they're like old minoan ruins there it's
like huge island there's like a lot of
dope ship there but also there's a lot
of cool islands too that are not
santorini and mykonos that you could get
still get a taste of grease from noxos
is one of my favorite islands it's
[ __ ] beautiful there's a lot of crazy
mountains old villages like when you go
up where my aunt lives we have a house
up in the mountains
in crete not noxos
it
it's such a crazy feeling because you
feel like you're
you know traveling back through time
there's a outhouse she has goats
she has a watermelon patch fig trees up
in the mountains the population of the
village is like seven
and it's like so [ __ ] old-school it
just feels like so rad you feel like
you're like i don't know traveling yeah
you feel like the last thing you want to
do is go [ __ ]
get on a plane and cut your trip short
exactly but you did i did
and
it was worth it i was really happy once
i got there and and it was cool because
like i don't really do obviously do like
a lot of serious acting but even though
this is like a dark comedy
the one
note was like you gotta deliver all your
lines seriously you know the whole tone
of the movie no smirking no trying to
make the lines clever same way
for free exactly very soon i'm very
serious about it right so
so yeah there's like a coven of like you
know like
kind of like gothy
[ __ ]
into witchcraft and crystals and [ __ ]
like this right right it's it we watched
the trailer and my takeaway from it was
that
like uh it was like a secret society
kind of a thing and the rule is you're
not allowed to be cool yeah pretty much
and then and then they find out that the
like the leader of the group
was like the class president and he was
a cool kid and he plays lacrosse
yeah you're one of the cool kids you're
not one of us you're not a rebel like us
yes right so then he has to go on a
mission to kind of find himself and find
out how
so it's a little bit of like a darker
kind of like uh revenge of the nerds
like
yeah but it's kind of like
it's like a dark comedy because it's
like
these characters are not self-aware
but people who watch it realize how much
of a [ __ ] joke they are but they
don't so it's kind of fun to watch like
you know how seriously they take
everything is like kind of like
laughable
um from the audience perspective because
they're like look at these [ __ ]
idiots and the [ __ ] they're saying yeah
but the fact that they take it so
seriously i think it was what makes the
tone of the film work and
kind of fun and and this is coming out
uh
what's the name of it it's coming out
december uh february 14th right yeah
it's called king night king night yeah
and what's it coming out on
[Laughter]
i don't know
you like that that's a call back
yeah um yeah i don't know i mean it's
definitely coming out on streaming
platforms everywhere and i think i think
they said it's gonna get like a limited
theater release too it's cool cool did
you do you feel like you want to do more
like more serious kind of acting i
really do i just i love it not not
necessarily like dark comedy serious
acting but like
i don't give a [ __ ] if i have to like if
i like a role like
i'm down to try like serious acting i
feel like
i feel like i could commit to it and i'm
not saying i'm the best or anything but
like i feel like i could do okay if i
really just i could just commit to a
character and really like click with the
character yeah man the godfather of
youtube the best the best
egotistical things but i feel like i've
stunned a lot of these kids and yeah if
i got a tv show out of viral videos
before youtube existed then yeah [ __ ]
that they my sons exactly that's right
yeah you got it on record you know
they're lucky
they like it they should thank their
lucky stars
they're lucky to be here you're lucky to
have me
yeah dude
it's epic so
like
the
you're showing mtv was in what like
around 2005
2004 to 7. wow okay 2004 to 7. yeah it
ran parallel to viva la bam oh wow epic
how did i not not know that man crazy
running parallel means right after each
other or before yeah it started
the right word but it was like uh i
think it was viva alabama in my show
after something ah
it was on that uh
whatever what they call it like sunday
suit something stupid is that right yeah
and did you your guys's past ever cross
in the early 2000s
i don't know
at a party
i've hung out with him a little bit but
we haven't had like any like full
[ __ ] days of like going out here and
there here and there i saw him at some
parties and [ __ ]
um
back in his uh when he was uh [ __ ] up
days you know yeah but um
just briefly you know what i mean
right
but um sorry
yeah like you've got the this
twitch thing going on like uh
your
balls deep in it you know you've been
that there's definitely made a lot of
noise you know around the rice gum thing
like uh you had the cooking show on
youtube
you know like
like i'll go through an airport and and
the like you know
before i get to security people like oh
my god oh dude [ __ ] let me get a
picture this is so great and then i'll
be going through security and the tsa
guy i'll be like man [ __ ] what happened
to you dude i haven't seen you on
anything in forever you know like and
and kind of like from an ego perspective
like you just don't
you know like you don't know like like
and that's the nature of the world today
with the digital world the internet like
you can be like so prolific and have
people just not [ __ ] know yeah
it's crazy like just imagine okay say
say your podcast right now a lot i'm
sure a lot of your fans watch it i'm
sure you got a lot of new fans from it
right yeah but just say
anybody that's ever seen you on any show
on jackass you know the movies whatever
all of a sudden simultaneously got like
a ping on their phone saying stevo has a
podcast here is here it is you can find
it here
yeah like how many more people would
start watching that podcast here i mean
it's like
you have to really be tuned in you have
to be looking at internet content all
the time to be like oh this person has
this now you know right you can't just
so just it's kind of funny like to think
like how many like if only more people
that [ __ ] with me knew i was doing this
one thing and had attention to see this
one thing it would just go crazier you
know yeah because like
that's it is what it is you've been
hustling non-stop like your entire
career you've never slowed down
what whatsoever
i mean i
to to be a little hard on myself i could
have worked 10 times harder okay yeah
like there are so many months where i'm
like oh yeah i could have gotten so much
more [ __ ] done than i did right
um and
people always ask me about regrets i
really don't have a lot of regrets in
life but sometimes i feel like that's
the one thing like
i should have pushed myself harder and
i'm not being
kind of like really rough on myself like
no like really really
some months
have been just way too [ __ ] lazy all
right i feel like i could have done more
do you think that uh all the weed that
you smell contributes to that or
not really because i think my persona of
a weed smoker is way different than what
i really am people come up to me all the
time and they're like bro i really love
to smoke with you it'd be kind of like a
dream i can't grow up with watching a
show
and i'm like nah i'm good first of all i
don't want to smoke with people who are
going to grill me and ask me questions
about you it's the worst high ever
and um
there was definitely a phase in l.a
probably like
maybe like 12 10 12 years ago where i
was just like smoking kind of regularly
like you know or maybe almost every day
but it was kind of like a small pocket
of time
and i have a i have some weed at the at
the hotel i got some v like weed vapes
and [ __ ]
i'm just a very finicky smoker i don't
smoke out of habit non-stop
i have to really really in the be in the
mood like oh i really want to smoke a
little bit i really feel like being a
little bit high right now and then i
smoke and then
months go by nothing
months and months
don't hit anything
i was in new york for like a year and a
half
probably smoked like maybe three or four
times in that year and a half now i'm in
la first thing i was like yeah let me
hit the weed shop
started smoking a little more i was
staying on venice beach for a month
smoking like kind of regularly but yeah
i'm very on and off with it and
i feel like weed effects on me have been
very minimal
okay
you got a youtube channel as well as all
the
like what are your platforms other than
twitter my platform it's kind of i guess
it's kind of embarrassing to some people
but i've been grinding tic toc i just
[ __ ] i finally hit a million on tick
tock i've been posting clips of my old
show i've been making some original [ __ ]
and
so it's basically like twitter
twitch
and tick tock insta i'm kind of like
letting die too i don't really post a
lot on instagram okay youtube if i was
smarter i would just never have let that
thought i would have just been posting
twitch clips every day or whatever but i
just haven't been
yeah man youtube is uh
right like um
machete was saying about boxing it's a
jealous god oh there you go yeah mm-hmm
yeah you did trejo yeah yeah
like if you ignore youtube
youtube is a jealous god man but you had
a banger
last week with the
yeah your video i mean you didn't post
before that for a while right
uh no i've been i've been picking it up
a little bit more yeah i've been uh you
got to feed the beast man youtube
doesn't like going hungry for me i kind
of had to pick like between twitch or
youtube and i started picking up youtube
again and like the [ __ ] that was just
getting popular was just like vlogs like
jake paul type [ __ ] and like making
sketch comedy just kind of was like dead
on youtube and um
i was just like
i had an opportunity for twitch like
right when twitch moved over to letting
you twitch used to not even allow you to
go outside to stream it had to be video
games
inside yeah damn and then i was doing
twitch as a hobby on and off
for that and then as soon as they were
like
you can go outside and stream with your
phone now whatever you want full camera
of just yourself walking around doing it
i was just like my views went from like
200 viewers to like 1500 viewers and
like my first [ __ ]
sorry my first [ __ ] full
outdoor stream
so
i was just like all right this is
popping let's just see how this works
and
yeah five years later do you play video
games
[Laughter]
[Music]
i do i do play video games um
actually he's just like walking his
finger over
[Laughter]
so there's one that you would find
interesting it's called
grand theft auto role play so it's gta 5
with mods and everybody
in the game is a character this is the
one where you want to kill as many
hookers as you can yes
so it's like grab that thought
that's what i feel in real life yeah
right that's how i play the game of life
i want to kill as many others as i can
so
um
yes it's like grand theft auto but
instead of just playing the game
normally every single person in the
world is an actual character
with a microphone
so like if you rob a bank
uh there's like okay actually people
playing cops chasing you and then they
put you in like so when you log in to
play the game you're assigned like okay
i'm logging in and they tell you okay
you're gonna be a cop instead of hit
something actually it's so [ __ ] nerdy
but to actually be a cop on this on the
big servers
you need like
months of like training
so do they pay you once you've been
trained or is it just like people are
that passionate they'll do it for free
no they'll they'll stream it on twitch
and they'll get paid off twitch
okay
like there's people that play lawyers in
the game there's people that play law
school you sit down in class and like i
mean it's not that that deep but like
the craziest [ __ ] when you rob a bank
with people and then the cops come and
you negotiate for you have to have a
hostage or also they'll just shoot you
right you negotiate for the hostage they
give you free passage and then there's a
huge [ __ ] cop chase if they catch you
they'll put you in a holding cell you'll
ask for a lawyer and the lawyer will
come and it's like this whole [ __ ]
very involved thing and it's kind of
nerdy how serious they take it but it
also makes it fun because if you could
just be like oh the cop you know like
i'm walking down the street and i'm just
shooting everybody the stakes aren't
high when you have to take it seriously
right it kind of makes it a little fun
you know wow
that uh
that that are people walking around like
oh like that's mickey mouse and this
guy's like that or do people everyone
looks like people you know like is your
avatar like all crazy um some people put
weird avatars but most people don't like
there's a fast food restaurant in the
game and they have a certain outfit they
wear and like you actually go in and
they're like can i take your order and
you like order food and [ __ ] it's like
this whole weird world morph gta there's
actually people playing the [ __ ] fast
food workers they're serving you burgers
yes
why would you want to be that character
because that character might
have something where he's getting
getting a drug dealer to come
and he's like buying drugs and you know
you got to serve meanwhile act like
you're really exactly and then someone
might come in and rob the place and you
might have this whole interaction where
you pull out your gun faster and shoot
them so like they can have their own sub
stories and [ __ ] like that it's super
involved so
you're at the mercy of how the game is
played like that you know like you can't
be like oh well i'm to try to make my
role in the game a little bit you know
more involved more bigger but like you
create your own stories
so like you can if you want to be a uh
if you want to be the boss of a gang you
need to find a bunch of four people like
four or five people that will follow you
and that will take your orders you name
the gang does that happen within the
confines of the game are you recruiting
this and setting it up outside within
the game everything is within the game
yeah turning into real life
is there like a leader like is there a
president or like within there's a
there's a town mayor that gets elected
wow there's a casino you could go in i
used to work in the casino in the game
and now that that's not like there's not
only one ecosystem for the whole game
it's like kind of
there's different servers but the best
server i think is called no pixel and
that's the one that's hard the hardest
to get into and some people that don't
have priority there's so many people
waiting to play some people will sit
around for six hours just to get in the
server wow wow yeah it's crazy
super crazy and do people know they're
dealing with scott just bail that got so
heavy for him he couldn't yeah yeah do
people know
you talk when they're uh yeah
that's a great question like do they
know like oh um
andy milinakis is robbing my bank right
now um most people do because i don't
use a voice changer i don't try to do a
crazy voice and i actually play a rapper
in the game
and i make music outside of the game to
play inside of the game that's relevant
to characters so i'll make diss tracks
about characters in the game holy [ __ ]
and i'll like actually do it in a studio
sometimes
and
so i'll have like a record release party
where it's like a diss track and i'll
like say so much [ __ ] about the actual
character's past and what he's doing and
i'll like play i'll play the diss track
and like wrap a diss track in the game
do you have like a nemesis within the
game
yeah
i do you want to shout them out do we
want to yeah [ __ ] ott his bars are whack
he's a fake drake and he uses too much
autotune boom but you have no idea who
he is in the real world he could be your
next-door neighbor oh you do i know a
little bit about them i don't know a lot
about them but like you don't
necessarily know
anything about any character you come
across
but it's fascinating you can you could
be like oh like some peop some people
off stream will be like oh yes so and so
play so and so and you'll check their
stream out and maybe you'll host them
because on twitch
you can kind of pay it forward yeah you
could like i if you have like a thousand
viewers and there's another streamer
streaming gta
you could just be like forward slash
host and you can send your viewers over
to them
so a lot of people do that within within
the gta community
but most of my [ __ ] that i do on twitch
that
has a much bigger viewership is like
when i travel and i go outside and i
just stream games once in a while and
you're holding a selfie stick the whole
time like
that what do you mean it's tyranny more
like it was strapped to a backpack
holding a stick but a lot of streamers
there's a there's a shoulder mount for
the camera oh okay and they do like
first person they'll ride bikes they'll
walk around but i feel like if it's your
stream they want to see your reactions
if i want to make jokes and [ __ ] they
should see your [ __ ] face so i just
yeah i just hold the selfie stick the
camera is really small though it's not
like a big dslr sony it's just like
sony's answer to gopro it's like a tiny
light camera
clamp with a phone to read what's going
on in the chat sure and then
yeah wow fascinating [ __ ]
and uh and
it's a [ __ ] ton of money that you're
making from it
i mean not getting it
no it's like it can be pretty good uh i
i'm
i don't know how much longer i'm gonna
do live streaming because i'm kind of
like
i'm kind of toning down the twitch
lately with all the other [ __ ] i'm
getting into cool so but i mean if i go
to japan i have to stream because i it's
so much fun to have an audience watching
what you're doing in japan yeah do you
have like sponsors flying you to japan
are you paying for that um sometimes i
get trips paid for
um
and when people subscribe to you on
twitch you know you make you make pretty
good money you know it's not that crazy
to make like you know
sometimes like 20 25k a month just from
just from like streaming
outdoors yeah you ever get like uh
flown to dubai by some like crazy
no um i got an offer to once but i was a
little bit creeped out because he said
the whole time i would have to be
sucking on his toes and then he would
give me lamborghini money
well well you coulda could have a
lamborghini though
true yeah it's good to have a
lamborghini
well yeah dude like uh it's too bad that
we don't know how to um tell people to
watch your movie
it's kind of classic though yeah
yeah just if you type in king night on
what was it february 14th valentine's
day king
night if you type in king night then
this one it'll come up it'll be like oh
streaming on i mean you know what like
that actually to be clear we recorded
this before february 14th by just a
couple days sorry hold on uh happy new
year xyz films will release
xyz will release king night on demand
and digital february 17 2021.
there you go february 17th on
i thought it was 17th you guys [ __ ] me
up no 17th february 17th all right
hey
we're on it dude friday february 17th
that's tomorrow as this comes out
good
there we go what's your dog's name again
wendy from peru
wendy she's the greatest you're great i
love that story well get on [ __ ] andy
melanocus's twitch
and watch his [ __ ] movie listen to
his rap do we have anywhere we can send
people to get to find uh a catalog of
your rap music
uh i do have a soundcloud but
i don't know you could see a lot i have
some music videos on my youtube i guess
that's good who are the biggest rappers
that you've recorded tracks with
um
hmm
i did one with rich the kid
that's sick little b i'm trying to think
i'm like kind of like drawing a blank
is there any talks of a three loko
reunion ever
i don't know simon is like killing the
movie scene right now with this movie
red rocket and he's kind of doesn't want
to rap anymore he said he's done it for
so long and he just he's getting movie
offers now and [ __ ] like that right so i
think he's kind of done with that and
riffraff just like blew up yeah i don't
know what riff is doing right now yeah
but
i'm gonna
[ __ ] around with that auto-tune kind of
like
not like rapping but rip rap would get
would get on that sucker dick for free
right he could do drop drop a hard verse
he would yeah he would do it yeah that
would be perfect let's get him in the
mix dude maybe you should drop some
vocals on it yeah steve did have a rap
career yeah i did
and i mean we haven't talked about your
rap redemption in so long but are you
still planning on doing that i i uh
maybe
i need to [ __ ] get in the studio and
i'll [ __ ]
you know
lay some bars down yeah by the way have
you ever seen
the celebrity death match with me versus
you oh dude
i feel like i vaguely remember that but
uh but no wow
that was so random for one
i think i won okay i think i ate you
i am not nice
cause i'm fat nice one mtv right on the
nose
um yeah
yeah now i'm thinking about reverse for
i'll suck your dick for free right yeah
i mean that's
you written all over it yeah dude i just
like uh bro you we need to [ __ ] around
without you doing auto-tune i'm thinking
about like i i i will clobber your dong
[ __ ]
you know
my my tonsils will not last long i will
[ __ ] hit your hog so hard
writes itself
beasting marks on your dick
i don't
i don't let me see
yeah
yeah dude i i i think it'd be it would
make a lot of sense for for you united
to do that's a great track for me to
yeah dust off my my i want to hear your
voice with like really buttery auto
tuned with you singing instead of
rapping because that could be really
that needs to be on a different track
because we should make a new track yeah
okay all right it could still be just as
dirty as suck your dick for free right
it should be a brand new track we'll
talk about it all right dude i'll dm you
on twitter and i'll give you my number
right now yeah until then stay tuned
tell them you're number two yes
enjoy uh enjoy uh
king night february 17th
so xyz films king night on demand and
digital february 17th 2022 yeah if you
watch it i'll suck your dick for free
dad i i i respect you i admire you hey
bro yeah dude i admire me too
thanks for doing this man thank you man
it's a [ __ ] honor [ __ ] yeah you did
yeah dude you know
i i really enjoyed andy and there's
something i've been meaning to tell you
guys the ones who stick around to the
very end a while back i saw a bunch of
people posting their um
screenshots of their spotify app i think
and it was listing like the their top
five podcast that they listened to and i
did there i saw a bunch where people
were like it's not how many hours
there's some people listening to hours
of wild ride man and i want to thank you
like especially you know this
they we're creeping up on 100 episodes
and it's uh
it's i never thought that it was going
to be as good of an experience as it is
now check it out we've got this
this whole new studio on the new tour
bus man
big things are happening man i'm really
grateful for you guys for sticking
around on this very wild ride
yeah dude
[Music]